basically all you do is talk to me okay
let me hear you just talk so i can see
hello perfect
okay good all right momo
yes mama where'd you grow up i grew up
in los angeles california
south central yes and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents
all right um my childhood my father he
lives in alabama my mother
she lives out here mom i grew up my mom
i moved from alabama when i was a baby i
never
i don't i still haven't seen my dad to
this day like i get to see him if i'm on
via car or chat or anything so that's
not really a big part of your life
no but he sends me money every month but
i put in my savings account for my mom
um that's not working out and uh
how was your childhood how old are you
i'm 14.
you're 14. so you're still a child yeah
still a child
how how is your childhood it's hard it's
not well i can't say it's hard
but it's difficult what kind of
pressures do you have as a 14 year old
growing up
in 2020 in south central
no it's good it's all right but it's not
our good it's not good because
when i go back home i gotta go on the
street
and go home and stuff one of my school
it's a whole different person you know
and people don't know like that and i
don't have friends like that i don't
talk to people like that school
so it's just like so they don't know
their friends or years at school that
are doing this
no my friends i don't know about them i
just go to school but i go to school
away from my home
i go to school i go to high school to
high school oh so you're going to school
far away from me yes i don't
go to school by home because what got
you attracted to this
um when i was younger when i was younger
i was living my granny on 46th and but
long
and she she was like she just do drugs
and everything
so she had come out i was embarrassed by
her because she would come outside
and i was already old enough to know
things i was like 11 10
yeah i was already knowing about stuff
like that because my uncles they
come in the house with guns and money
all type of stuff and my granny [ __ ] do
drugs
at the middle of the night but in the
morning she'd be regular but at night
time
she had come back to a whole person but
in the morning she had wake up in the
morning off of drugs
she i remember she ran outside and um
i'm not trying to cry but she ran
outside and then she
like she all her clothes would be off
like everything my friends used to be
able to see it all
and i used to be like dang like she'd
come outside and we're naked
naked talking about some snake on her
it's a snake on her
and i'll be like no it's like i tell my
friends every time i go back squats to
my friends
oh she'd just be tripping like she got a
problem or stuff she'd have medical
problems and stuff
and i'll tell him that and she had come
back in the house but she like
she just got crazy on us and said it's a
snake on her all the time in the kitchen
and we used to be like it's not a snake
on her and then mommy used to tell my
son i'll start telling me like about
she do drugs and stuff and that's why i
started knowing about drugs but
i didn't put myself to it until i met my
boyfriend
until i met this boyfriend and then this
is when i was in eighth grade eighth
grade i met a boyfriend
and he was like how was he 19 yes he was
19.
and i was how i was like 13 yeah 13
and then he every day he had come get me
every day after school
but he never he was acting real nice he
was real nice when i first met him real
nice like a regular boyfriend but i know
about boyfriends and stuff until he told
me he liked me and he wanted to date me
so
after that that's when um i went to
school
one day he came and got me after school
and he was telling me about
figure roy and how girls would be out
there but i lived
after i moved from on 46th and butlon we
went to vegas but we came back to l.a
and then we was on fig and 75th this is
where my granny used to live
and we just always stay with her and my
mom me mom and my sister stay with her
and then that's when he came and got me
one day
but i'm already knowing about um fig
because i live on fake and
75th so you see it yes i see everything
out there i walk to the corner store
with my cousins get food
and i see girls so i felt like i was
like oh
they say they make money so i'm in my
head before he even came in before we
met him i'm already knowing about oh
it's fake it's a lot of girls that be
out there they make a lot of money so
i'm wanting to do it
so i'm i'm in my head wanting to do my
cousin's like don't do that
i didn't listen to them i don't care
about what y'all talking about so
this is why i met him and then he was
telling me about fake and everything
so that's when he had told me look i was
walking to school with another boy
but i wasn't like i didn't know nothing
about boyfriend or girlfriend i wasn't
trying to
be on a weird stuff trying to be another
boy i was walking with the other boy
and he socked me in front of all my
friends like literally from all my
friends
and i was crying and everything and then
he i went outside the um i was walking
outside so i called my mom but i
couldn't call my mom and hurry so he put
me in a car and tell me
oh you're gonna go on figaro and you're
gonna hope for me you're gonna give me
back the money everything so i'm just
thinking like what can i do
i can't tell my mom and everything so i
just did it i went out there
and when i did it i was so scared but i
wasn't i wasn't too scared to the point
i couldn't do it but i was scared like i
just got socked in front of my friends
so what
they're going to probably come back to
me telling me stuff like what was going
on with you like they don't you know how
people be is
so then i when i went out there i was
scared but i got two guys like two guys
and then
they wanted me to suck their dick and
stuff so i did that
but then i only got a little bit of
money like how much do you have like
fifty dollars
i have fifty dollars and i know about
figuring out that stuff so i
came back to him he saw me he came and
got me but i realized he had other girls
working for him
so i'm looking at them and it was they
was calling my name but i didn't know
like i never met them i guess he told
them me
talked about me so i went to them and
they was telling me
oh he gonna get mad at you don't give
him that don't give him fifty dollars
he's gonna beat you
and i listen to him so i just went in
the car and he started beating me and i
went back home
the same day after he dropped me off he
dropped me off
on the corner and he was like um he was
like tomorrow imma come get you again
and i was like uh-uh like i'm thinking
my head like no
like i'm scared stuff i don't tell my
mom so i came back home but i was still
i was bleeding like i had a bro my eye
was bruised so my nose was busted
and my lip was busted and i went in the
house and i told mama i got into a fight
with a girl
so she wouldn't like think i was out
there
but i was surprised that they didn't see
me because we live on the same street
so that's when um he came and got me the
same day after school i catch the bus to
go to school by myself
and he'd come get me after school but
he'd be out there like just posting in
front of my school
post out of nowhere and my friends would
be like looking at stuff
and i'll just be like oh yeah it's just
my friend this is my friend it was like
no because he talked to you the other
day
and i just i stopped talking that broke
me off with all my friends i didn't have
no more friends after that because they
found like they
they was like uh-uh she's not listening
to us so that's when he kept
recently like kept like just kept having
me hold on the street
but i kept coming back with a little bit
of money because i didn't know like
until the girls i started listening to
the girls that was telling me i came
back with a little bit of money
and he he beat me again like he was just
beating me and i said you were working
figaro every every yes like every day
basically yes after school like i have
to
he gave me some clothes to put on he
gave me some clothes he'd go to the
trunk give me a club some clothes
and some sandals and that's how i really
started that's how now i'll be wearing
sandals so
what what do you think got you into this
doing this because
because i started seeing other females
on their own fake and seeing other girls
yes and that would make me want to do it
and then you got involved yes and you
turned out to be attempting yes
and i saw that's how that's crazy how
god works because that's
crazy how i was looking at it
like oh yeah i should do that idea how
much money were you making i don't know
where i was making like
when i when i really started knowing
about how much money i'm supposed to
make i was making like 200
300 400 one day like 500 hours like
about that amount like 200 to 500 hours
that's how much money i was making
you're at home
yes like i was like oh you said how old
about i agree
i was 13 yes 13. you're still doing it
at 14. yes
i'm talking are you working with a pimp
still no i'm not working with the same
pimp no more i
thought because he one day what day was
that
he came and got me and he was like oh
i'm gonna be moving somewhere and all
type of stuff talk about making up
lies just making a blast i'm already
know he lying so while i'm moving
i'm i'm not gonna see you no more so
then i start thinking to myself i'll
make the money by myself
so now i'm working by myself like just
making money by myself because
he left so i don't know what happened to
him so yeah
and and your mom doesn't step in and say
you know
yes my mom stepped in all the time
that's what carmen break my heart like
it break my heart because she step in
and tell me to stop
and i i will stop but like i'm addicted
to it now so i can't stop and i
have that because i met your mom and she
wants the best for you yeah my granny
too
everybody do yeah and my auntie she do
it so i
i feel like i'm comfortable with doing
it but i'm not because mama told me to
stop
but i've been stopped i've been trying
to stop lately but yesterday i stopped
like i didn't go yesterday like i just
stopped i just stopped going for like a
week
like this week i stopped going but i
felt this yesterday
i went out at nighttime but i came back
in the house but i didn't make no
money or nothing i just came back look
what kind of guys pick you up
it was a um some mexican guy that was a
mexican guy and they thought that guys
are nice to you or they're me
some one of them was nice but he was
trying to force me to do stuff for him
that i didn't want to do with him like
but i did it and then i was feeling bad
but i didn't he gave me no money so i
just walked the house and i was just
crying and every type of stuff
i was just crying i mean it's a very
dangerous lifestyle yeah it's really
what do you think about your self-worth
or your
your i feel like i feel like i shouldn't
do it but what what what
what makes it okay in your head to do it
i don't know seeing other girls on the
street
and i just feel like you look up to them
yeah i just feel like i should do it
like that yeah and i'm
i just like i'm addicted to it i need to
yeah there's something very attractive
about the lifestyle
yeah it is it is like it's it's
attractive with attention like you
a lot of people see you if it's like
this the attention really to me i feel
like i said attention
like when i saw they look at me i'd be
like oh
i'm insecure myself i feel like i'm not
beautiful i don't think i'm cute
or nothing like that i try and then when
i'm out there if like people come to me
and all type of stuff and they say i'm
beautiful on type of stuff and that
and make me happy but i gave my family
too but
it don't feel i don't feel the same way
how i feel out there you know well
your dad's not giving it to you my dad
yeah i don't know
my dad in my life like my sister dad
died
and i just like i don't got no father
figure like i just like he was just a
bird donor i saw phil
at the end of the day but yeah if you
had a dad you probably wouldn't be doing
it yeah that's my
mom told me i had to she was like if he
was in your life you and i do this but
he gave me money for my love you know
how people give you money just for them
just that but that's how i feel like
outside on the street they getting money
just for that like just to have sex and
do all this stuff
and my dad just gave money just for he
that i got he loved me
don't like he just gave me money he
every time i called him he had like he
want to talk to me you don't want to
talk to me
the first thing he said is oh do you
need some money
so that's why that's how i get money
hungry and that's when i start asking
for more money and i
but i still i feel like i'm still there
like i still if i could be able to save
my money up then i could be able to
do other things in life but what i do
here
i always do people here i do people here
on the street i do hose hair
at the time but they come to my house
and i do the hair and mom would be
looking like
mom be disappointed but i'm doing it for
money but she'll take the money and put
it up for me like
i appreciate mom for that because i
still got money put up at the end of the
day if
i don't have no money in a world you
know but you ever been arrested
yeah yes plenty of times head yes please
stay with a 14 year old girl who's
working
they they was just they took me home
they didn't take me jail they never take
me to jail they always take me home
but they said that when it's gonna
affect me when i get older because i got
all these
jail warnings and stuff and it's going
to affect me
but we've been to the county building
they said they're going to let me like
they're going
i'm on probation nothing like that they
just said they're going to try to work
with me and try to tell me to stop doing
this because i got arrested
like how many times five times for
prostituting because they called me on
the street with other girls and they'd
come get us
and i'm relationship um arrested when i
was 13. i used to hang out with my
friends and we used to go
driving around the cars but they didn't
have license you know
and we used to be driving and one day i
was driving the car and then i got
pulled over and i went i had got
with the thing but i didn't go to jail
cause i'm young so
they just always take me home but they
tell every time i go to the county
building i mean not the county
the uh court place they tell me
everything they said i need to work on
it because
if i when i get older it could affect me
like i'm gonna be i could be in jail for
more than what i think or whatever so
yeah that's what's going on
are drugs a part of your life yes you
said drugs yes i've been i've been on
drugs before
i was um when i was 14 after after he
had put me in his car everything
he was telling me to try try crack
cocaine crack and
i tried crystal too but i really smoked
weed i don't i never when i was 13 i
never smoked
like stuff like that until i met him but
your pimp was giving you yes he was
giving me drugs and that's what that's
another thing that made me
um think that i was okay because i was
doing drugs and the drugs take over me
and i'll be out there acting crazy one
day he gave me a
what's that um what it's a acid
acid take it and i was so that dad was
so happy i was just making a lot of
money i was
with my friends and then one day i did a
threesome with my other two friends
and i was thinking like uh i was so
scared and now
that day i went home i just went home
and there are other girls your age doing
this yes like 13
yes 12 it's not it's a girl i know it's
12 but i think she lying i don't know if
she's 12 or
i don't know i can't believe nobody out
there really i can't trust nobody out
there
because i don't know because one day i
got into i got jumped one day by
a couple of girls because they said that
i was looking at the pimp or something
like that
but they pimp actually was looking at me
like he was shot he was trying to help
me go with them and
i got jumped one day and that's the day
i got um you see a scar right here in my
face it's a scar right here
but it was deep like it was i got um
they kicked my face i had
i went to the hospital and i had bumps
on my head everything
and then i started that's after i
stopped because i started getting scared
i was like i'm not trying to get
um out there get jumped no more and
stuff but i was just going with the flow
i was just going with it i just kept
doing it
and i was just like and i [ __ ] took
over me but
i still did my hair but it take over me
like i can't even
do things i want to do my friends
because i want to go on the street so
bad
like that don't make no sense you want
to do it yeah sometimes something
something draws you to it yeah but you
get depressed sometimes
yeah heck yes believe me like only i get
depressed but i try not to let that take
over me too like i'll just be sitting
there like
stop worrying about that i'll go get
some weed my sister's taking me to the
weed shop
and then i'll be calm like i'll be okay
and i smile i fight when i smoke weed
and take everything away you know i
don't gotta worry about nothing but i
still be worried about it but
i don't gotta worry about like as much
as i worry about when i'm not off work
as a young teen are there things that
you dream about doing in life
yes a lot of things that you have in a
hair shop being in a hair shop me and
bring
me very hair i do braids i do hair all
the time yes i got like five
five customers i always do hair i'm
feeling i'm working up to get a youtube
i'm working up to get a camera to have
me a youtube so i can make new hair
because i see a lot of people on youtube
that do hair
and i'm good at my skin i'm good at
doing hair i just did my mama hair i did
all the hair
and yeah i do my granny hair everything
i'm working on learning how to do um
haircut like i'm saying my granny hair
is trimmed i'm working on how to do that
but i know how to braid everything i've
been yeah i break hair
that would be a career for you that you
could actually yeah cause massages you
could actually feel good about what
you're doing yeah
whereas figueroa probably does the
opposite
yeah i figure it's just it's hard about
being out there it's just hard
like dang it's like you gotta
you gotta work up to get the money and
everything and it's i feel like me being
not having a pimp is better for me i'm
having a pit because
i'll get to have the money at the end of
the day i'm nobody gotta pet me and beat
me around
like how how it used to happen and stuff
i don't know about do you think you're
addicted to the
lifestyle yeah yes i already think i'm
addicted and i'm trying to hear that
from all the girls
yes i think i'm i'm trying to like i've
been trying
so bad but it's not working but again
i'm trust i trust myself i trust that
when i turn
at least like 17 or 16 i'll stop because
some people they learn from at 17 they
start doing around 16 i know
girls that told me that they've been
doing around 16 17 and they
stopped like at 20 or 21 like my auntie
she
she had my stop like and that's that's
another thing that motivated me because
i flagged my
seat do it and i was like it's okay but
it's really not it's not okay
but i try i think it's okay sometimes
like okay i don't care what nobody
thinks or
i get insecure and i fight i should go
on the street and i'll get attention or
something like that
so it's the combination of the fast
money the attention yes like that's what
it is i'm sure it's exciting and
dangerous
yeah it's like it the dangerous ah i
already get a danger like that except
for the time i got jumped in
why have got shot at before i got shot
at that was all gone
that was worse like that was worse my
best friend she got shot in her leg
yeah i mean do you ever just like look i
mean i know you're young and
you've been doing this a year or so but
do you ever look at it and go jesus this
is crazy that i'm doing this yeah
your friends must yes they always tell
me like just just stop doing this it's
not going to get you nowhere
and i understand but the money it's the
money that
but that gave me there but i'll try it
i'll be worried about the money a lot i
worry about the attention
but if you if you had a dad in your life
who was this yes it would be so much
better because
he when i got to phoenix i get to crying
and stuff
but i try and not cry but i cry about
things i do
but it's me i can't do nothing about it
until
i feel like i should stop you know
what do you think would help you now at
14 to stop um my mom
my mom helped me like she she helped me
mom is my number one
your mom saw it like my mama she she
makes sure like she
if i go out there she would be like
uh-uh i should be gone if i go out there
i should like i should be gone that's
the reason i really go out there she'd
be going somewhere
or at work or something and she'd be
gone and then
i just go out there and then when she
come back home she'll see like
something wrong with me or i'm high off
something or
um i'm tripping or i got bruised on me
or something but i have like that's
before though but now i don't get
bruised or
after i got jumped like i'll be talking
to females out there like that
but i have to two friends as one of them
named brittany and
they white they white girls like
straight white they're not even like
they straight up but
it's a it's a man that live on it's he
on broadway
it's a man on broadway um something and
um he
it's a whole house like it's a trap
house and all of them being in there but
i don't like going there because the
pimp he had pimp his name
he'd be he'd be doing all type stuff he
had pimp and like they'd be doing all
type stuff there and i'd be like no i'm
not
like no i'm not going to go over there
because one of the girls i was friends
with to work for him
and i'll be like like whoa like no i'm
not trying to deal with that stuff
because if i go over there
it's going to be a lot of drama between
other girls or him
trying to get me to get go with them and
stuff and i'd be like no so i just stay
with myself
now or i'll just build my friend my
other friend
and we'll just be riding around
sometimes
oh yeah like that i'll just try that
when i go my friends that stopped me
from going on fake a little bit
because that gave me a different life of
me with my friends like at school and
stuff you know
that's how i feel a little bit yeah i
mean what do you think would help you
stop
what helped me is
[Music]
other people telling me like to stop
that's what helped me to stop because
but what really helped me oh
i don't even know what would help me to
stop watch some of the videos on my
channel and see where these girls
are my auntie i was really crying yeah
that that did like
none of the none of the older women are
saying this is a great thing
they're also i mean not not that that's
what's really
the cure for your situation i think
having your dad not around yeah that's
the main thing
because i don't even get to i don't get
to talk to him
and he don't either way alabama you know
that's far from l.a
and we're trying to work our way to go
out there but mama she have to pay the
bills and everything else
but i'm saving my money to go out there
and see my dad because my grandma died
on my granny side she
she deaf and i don't i want to at least
see her before she go you know
like before she go because i said
because i won't be able to see my dad
mom and she she used to owe me
everything so i feel
i feel bad so i need to go see her
because that's like
that's another person out i love my life
like really bad
and yeah my mom she's my own dad your
mom is great i met your mom on father's
day
she every day every day on friday she
always wear um
you know things the um we were when the
man wear a suit they were
what is that car i forgot see the car
yeah the tie
and it she always wear that all the time
and she's just like a man you know i
finished up yeah
all of them do that all the time because
you're your mom is bona fide
yes sister yeah that's her blood sister
my
mom was the oldest out of all my granny
kids the oldest she we got my uncle
just he my uncle lived in vegas and he
told me like he
he don't know i i really do it like
mommy tell him no because like she don't
want him to get mad and stuff you know
because he get mad he really aggressive
because that's my granny brother you
know
yeah that's my grandfather and she don't
they don't play that stuff
so yeah and that's like
that's hard your mom your mom's doing
her best yeah she is
she mom a good mother she she out
all my mama siblings have for them is it
i have my cousins there in the system so
i don't be here to see my cousins but
they gonna come out they go
they're gonna be here i'm better to see
them like i seen one of my other cousins
she crazy like like my so sonia ma
bona fide her own her kids she my cousin
she was on live one day and like she
shot her whole body on life
and i'm like what the freaking she had
in my auntie my other
my mama's other sister and like my
sister she was crying calling me a shoe
like
like you ready to stop she was talking
about he stopped being a fake and
everything because look what's
look what your cousin is doing show her
on internet showing her body and adding
her family members and
everything and i'll be trying to tell
her like i'll give my cousin's shoes
like the ones that like got a thought i
give them shoes because that's my
favorite
thing is shoes and clothes and jewelry
and i always like give them stuff
because they all got the stuff that they
like i got so i'll be like oh you can
have these shoes or you can have this
chain or
something like stuff like that he's
growing up in the hood also part of the
problem
huh he's growing up in the hood part of
the process that is this stuff
it's hard because like dang you guys see
you guys you guys see shooting you got
to see
people um fighting on the street you got
to see um
people trying to it's crazy because you
are you gotta do all type of stuff in
here you gotta see
people trying to get at you it's too
much stuff like it's too much stuff
people wanna fight you over just dumb
stuff haters there's all this type of
stuff
over there but i can't do anybody
because that's where i live where else
i'm gonna be at yeah
no you're growing up in a nice
neighborhood for real you know
you drive down figueroa what are you
gonna say like what am i supposed to see
like
what am i gonna do you're gonna see tim
some prostitutes yeah
and i'll go to my friends i had this one
friend like her dad her um uncle is
russell woodbrick
what's his name yeah basketball player
yes and i went with her to his house
i've been there facebook i've been to
face people i was like i've been in his
house
i've been a caitlyn frisco's um rap here
rapper caitlin for fro i've been
a lot of people like but yeah but i
don't let that get to me but i like that
life
i get to see you're a very smart girl
yeah yeah you're very smart and mature
but
at some point you need to figure out how
to change direction
right because and you're even talented
you know you you have things you could
be doing
yeah but but i i can tell you as an
outsider
you know some white white dude that's
got some nice cameras
you're making a mistake by following
that line yeah i'm trying to yeah i'm
really trying to stop
like yeah but every time i think about
it i
i think about it like i'm gonna stop but
when i see somebody else out there and
make me want to go out there
and then i'll come back in the house
sometimes i buy you know i'm not gonna
keep doing this but
it still affect me like still out there
today it's going to affect me
and i'll try to stop but my i get from
my mom
my everybody but it's because i grew up
around stuff like that so i can't
change my life i'm making me a whole
different person but i can because
in the future what am i going to do like
what am i going to do
so i've got to change my life so yeah
that's all i've been thinking
really yeah well mama helped you figure
this out and
change your direction because because
you're such a lovely young girl and it'd
be great to see you just
figure this out at a young age and make
it make it make the right decision right
i hope you figure that out hi john well
thank you for coming in all right
i just cried a lot oh it's okay i like
when i cry though because they make me
feel better
yeah it makes me feel more so much
better because i fight crying is better
i have to deal with i try i'm just now i
see you i feel
you like my dad i don't know i see you
as my dad right here call me
probably probably yeah i'll treat me
like your dad i'll give you great advice
that your dad should cause i'll see you
as my real dad phil i don't know why but
i see that's my dad cause
my dad don't even